all right now we turn to south dakota in
the wake of the road decision
the state is one of the few places that
had on their books since i believe 2005
outlawed abortion a trigger law as they
call it in other words if roe is
overturned they would trigger that and
they do have an exception to save the
life of the mother here to explain a
brand new book just out today
you can get on
amazon.comhannity.com bookstores
everywhere it's not my first rodeo
lessons from the heartland south dakota
governor christie noma is with us you
know um i asked you a question on radio
today and i want to ask you about your
book in a second
about
how to stop the people of south dakota
feel because i look at the supreme court
and their gun decision was clear we have
an enumerated right in the constitution
the right to keep and to bear arms
there's no enumerated right for abortion
but our framers had provisions the tenth
amendment the ninth amendment that
allows them
to
hand it off to the states where then the
people will elect the officials that
will make that decision based on their
state values uh is are these the values
of the people of south dakota i would
assume they are yeah i think the people
of south dakota really appreciate the
fact that the supreme court did its job
here
you know years ago they made a wrong
decision and to when they put this
decision back
last week what they did was put this
authority at the state level which is
where it should have always been so
we'll have this conversation in south
dakota we have a bill that passed back
in 2005 that said if roe was ever
overturned
that it would become illegal in our
state to have an abortion unless it was
to save the life of a mother
you know there have been different
ballot initiatives over the years i'm
sure it'll continue to be a debate but
i'm proud of the fact that my state
stands for life they recognize that
every single life is precious
and that this is something that's very
clear that the people will have a debate
with now i know that the public out
there doesn't necessarily know
uh the latest science and technology and
developments that we now know in the
last 10 years that we didn't know
previously about what happens to a baby
in the womb what they feel the pain they
feel all of that is an education process
that so many of us need to continue to
talk about and it's important that we
talk about supporting mothers that what
we have for programs to come alongside
people in this unplanned pregnancy or a
crisis situation that's facing them how
do they get health care how do they get
people to walk alongside them
financially what do they need and how do
we connect them to adoptive families if
that's the route that they choose
yeah we have states like new york now
actively promoting the idea that oh if
you can't get a late term abortion in
your state come to our state uh i think
in south dakota you promote mount
rushmore
we do it's shocking to me that the
governor of new york wants that to be
the legacy of her state
ending life come here if you want to end
a life
we do know that that there's
consequences for leadership but boy
i'd much rather
be proud of my state for standing for
freedom for liberty for honoring great
leaders who let our
country in times of crisis so you know
it's it's important to us that we
continue to talk to people about this
issue
because it is something that is so
important so timely and frankly we've
seen the supreme court make some really
big decisions this last week that really
upheld our constitution i'm so grateful
for them for doing their job
let me ask you i i learned a lot about
you as i read not my first rodeo
i didn't know you lost your father at a
young age i didn't know
that you decided to stay and work on the
ranch
all of the life
life lessons you learned doing so
i think there's a big part of your life
that a lot of people don't know about
tell us why those values how did they
shape you into the person you are today
i think the way i was raised
is why i'm who i am today you know my my
dad was a cowboy he was tough um he was
actually one of my best friends my my
whole life's plan was to
grow up go to school and come back and
run businesses with him farm and ranch
and and live the rest of my life there
uh with our family together that
dramatically changed when he was killed
it threw us into a situation where we
were hit with death taxes
all of a sudden we have this tragedy
he's killed at the age of 49
and then we have a federal law
threatening taking away our entire
family business so that's what got me
involved in government and politics and
it was very trying for took me 10 years
to pay off those taxes and we almost
lost our family business went through
other challenges over the years but the
way i grew up the family that i had our
faith
created the person that i am today and
that's how i make my decisions is from
my value system and i'm hopeful that
people will not just know me for covid
now they'll recognize that this that
covid wasn't my first rodeo i went
through a lot of other challenges in my
life but i'm proud of the fact that it
made me strong it made me a good
decision maker and that it made me want
to serve people
your name gets mentioned a lot when it
comes to potentially being a president
or a vice president one day you give it
any thought
well people ask so often that you have
to give it a thought but i'm hoping that
people will re-elect me to be the
governor of south dakota it's not in my
plans i truly just want to continue to
focus on our state we've got some unique
opportunities we've got the best economy
in the country we've got the fastest
growing incomes in our state people are
thriving doing well they're happier than
in other states i think that's a
testimony to the rest of the country
of what really is possible when you do
conservative policies that it really
does benefit our families so the fact
that we are an example right now to the
rest of the country and a little bit of
hope that's what we desperately need so
i'll continue to do what i can to make
sure we keep this country as great
as i had the chance to grow up in i want
my granddaughter to have the same
opportunity
incredible life story
not my first rodeo bookstores everywhere
amazon.com governor thank you so much
for being with us we appreciate it as
always coming up hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else